ce débat sur l'aide médicale à mourir
continue de susciter beaucoup de
discussions n'est pas justifié chez nous
julie bonsoir soir à ce qu'en belgique à
trois médecins qui sont poursuivis en
justice pour avoir aidé une femme mettre
fin à ses jours
oui tout à fait il s'agit même du tout
premier procès là-bas faut dire depuis
qu'on a donc légaliser l'euthanasie ni
plus ni moins donc que le royaume de
belgique a légalisé en 2002 alors dans
ce cas si les faits allégués remontent à
un peu après d'une dizaine d'années donc
en avril 2010 alors qu'une jeune femme
de 38 ans fait la demande pour avoir
l'aide médicale à mourir c'est cette
femme au centre de la photo tine nice
ses deux soeurs lot et se fieront des
années plus tard geneviève briser le
silence raconter ce qu'elles ont vécu à
travers tout ça est ce qu'elle qualifie
comme étant une expérience inhumaine de
fait de manière amateur distel elles se
sont donc confié à des médias et par la
suite ont entamé des démarches
judiciaires
si bien que maintenant ce sont trois
médecins parce qu'il fallait trois
signatures pour faire le processus de
thann asie ces trois médecins qui sont
maintenant visés par des accusations de
meurtre sur la base d'un empoisonnement
donc ayant causé la mort intéressant ce
serait intéressant suivre ça cela dit le
nombre de pays qui autorisent cette
pratique a augmenté au cours des années
exactement ça reste minoritaire mais
plusieurs pays emboîtent le pas donc et
poursuivre en ce sens parmi les plus
récents vont se tourner vers l'océanie
d'abord il ya eu l'australie qui a
légiféré en fait dans deux de ces états
il ya eu d'abord l'état de victoria en
2017 puis l'état d'australie occidentale
c'est en décembre dernier de ce côté ça
va prendre 18 mois avant d'entrer en
vigueur selon les pays vous savez
parfois on parle soit d'euthanasie
passive ou encore de suicide assisté en
ça peut prendre diverses formes toujours
donc en océanie cette fois ci la
nouvelle zélande qui a entamé une loi en
ce sens en novembre dernier rang
référendum dans la prochaine année est
vraiment les précurseurs ce sont les
suisses sont les premiers à avoir
dépénalisé ses formes de suicide assisté
en 1942 et surtout la suisse permet à
tous les étrangers aux gens provenant
d'autres pays de profiter de bénéficier
donc de ce service d'où le fait que
plusieurs viennent d'autres pays
européens note
man et sinon les plus connus comme chef
de file dans ce domaine ce sont les pays
du benelux évidemment belgique pays bas
et luxembourg ou même en belgique on
permet aux enfants sans restriction
d'âge de bénéficier donc de ses services
évidemment dans un cas de très grave là
de conditions médicales particulières
avec bien sûr la probation parental
toujours merci julie en prix